What steps should I take during the minimized damage?
So this is what we're talking about.
What steps should I take after radiation and chemo to facilitate toxification?
So during again, you'd go off of antioxidants for 48 hours,
because that's really when the chemo is doing its main work.
However, chemo is an oxidizing agent, so you don't want to negate the effects
of chemo if you're going to do chemo.
And after you're done with radiation is also an oxidizing agent.
And when you're done with radiation and when you're done with after 48 hours of chemo,
then you could hit hard antioxidants to pull that stuff out of your body.
I went to vegan this winter and dropped unintentionally 20 pounds and 5,
5, 110 tried to gain weight.
I do chemo and radiation with kind of nutritional strategies.
Should I employ during the treatments to avoid losing any more weight?
And the feeding tube has been recommended.
If you need to, would I would only recommend if you need the feeding tube?
Like you can't swallow.
They're thinking because it's had neck cancer and the radiation is,
you might end up with such a painful throat that you won't want to eat.
And it's going to be hard to get you to eat because it's going to be painful.
Then you do not want to lose weight.
You don't have weight to lose.
So you may have to consider getting a feeding tube to get the calories so you don't lose weight.